Vidéo: Narrateur: Un évènement vu d'un point de vue
donne une impression.
Vu d'un autre point de vue, il donne une impression tout à fait différente.
Mais c'est seulement lorsque vous obtenez l'intégralité de l'image que vous êtes en mesure de comprendre totalement
ce qui se passe.
Sasha Vucinic: C'est une sacré vidéo, n'est ce pas?
Et je trouve qu'en 29 secondes, cela nous apprend plus sur
le pouvoir et l'importance des médias indépendants
que je ne pourrais en dire en une heure.
Alors j'ai pensé que ça serait bien de commencer par ça.
Et aussi de commencer avec quelques statistiques.
D'après les chercheurs compétents, 83 pour cent de la population de cette planète
vivent dans des sociétés dépourvues de presse indépendante.
Pensez à ce nombre: 83 pour cent de la population sur la planète entière
ne savent pas vraiment ce qu'il se passe dans leurs pays.
Les informations qu'ils reçoivent sont filtrées par quelqu'un
qui, soit déforme ces informations, soit fausse ces informations,
fait quelque chose avec.
Donc ils sont dans l'incapacité de comprendre leur réalité.
C'est juste histoire de comprendre à quel point ce problème est important et préoccupant.
Maintenant, ceux d'entre vous qui ont la chance de vivre dans ces sociétés
qui représentent 17 pour cent, je pense, devraient en profiter pendant que ça dure.
Vous savez, le dimanche matin vous feuilletez le journal, préparer votre cappuccino.
Profitez-en pendant que ça dure.
Parce que comme nous l'avons entendu hier, des pays peuvent laisser tomber les étoiles de leur drapeau,
mais ils peuvent également perdre la liberté de la presse,
j'imagine que des Américains parmi nous peuvent nous en dire plus à ce propos.
Mais c'est un autre sujet complètement à part.
Alors je vais revenir sur mon histoire.
Mon histoire commence -- l'histoire que je veux partager -- commence en 1991.
A l'époque, je dirigeais B92, le seul media indépendant,
d'ailleurs le seul média électronique du pays.
Et je suppose que nous partagions -- nous avions la vie ordinaire d'un unique
média indépendant sur le territoire national, opérant dans un environnement hostile,
où le gouvernement veut vraiment rendre votre vie misérable.
Et il y a plusieurs façons.
Yeah, c'était le plat du jour:
un peu de menaces, un peu de conseils amicaux,
un peu de police financière, un peu de contrôle du texte.
Alors vous avez toujours quelqu'un qui reste dans votre bureau.
Mais ce qu'ils font vraiment, ce qui est réellement puissant,
et c'est ce que les gouvernements ont commencé à faire à la fin des années 90
si ils n'aiment pas les sociétés de média indépendantes --
vous savez, ils menacent vos associés publicitaires.
Une fois qu'ils sont menacés, vos forces de marché publicitaires sont en fait,
vous savez, détruites, et les publicitaires ne veulent pas venir --
peu importe à quel point cela serait une bonne idée pour eux --
ne veulent pas venir et faire de la pub.
Et vous avez un problème pour joindre les deux bouts.
A cette époque, au début des années 90, nous avions ce problème,
qui était, vous savez, principalement, survivre
mais ce qui était vraiment douloureux c'était,
souvenez vous, au début des années 90, la Yougoslavie se désintègre.
Nous étions assis sans bouger là-bas avec un pays en chute libre,
dégringolant au ralenti.
Et nous avions tous tout ça sur cassette.
Nous avions la capacité de comprendre ce qui se passait.
Nous étions vraiment en train d'enregistrer l'histoire.
Le problème était que nous devions réenregistrer cette histoire une semaine plus tard;
parce que si nous ne le faisions pas, nous ne pouvions pas nous permettre d'avoir assez de cassettes
pour garder des archives de cette histoire.
Alors si je vous ai donné cette image, je ne veux pas m'étendre trop là dessus.
Dans ce contexte-là et à cette période un monsieur est venu à mon bureau.
On était toujours en 1991.
Il dirigeait une organisation de systèmes de médias
qui existe toujours, le monsieur est encore dans les affaires.
Et qu'est-ce que je savais à l'époque des systèmes de médias?
J'aurais pensé que les systèmes de médias étaient des organisations,
ce que signifie qu'elles devraient vous aider.
Alors j'ai préparé deux plans pour ce rendez-vous, deux plans stratégiques.
Le petit et le grand.
Le petit était, je voulais essentiellement qu'il
nous aide à obtenir ces satanées cassettes,
pour que nous puissions garder ces archives pour les 50 prochaines années.
Le grand plan était de lui demander un prêt d'un million de dollars.
Parce que je pensais, je le pense toujours
que les entreprises médiatiques sérieuses et indépendantes sont des affaires florissantes.
Et je pensais que B92 survivrait et serait une grande entreprise
une fois que Milosevic serait parti, ce qui s'avèrera être vrai.
C'est probablement, soit la plus grosse, soit la seconde plus grossse
entreprise médiatique du pays.
Et je pensais que la seule chose dont nous avions besoin à l'époque
était un prêt de un million de dollars pour nous aider à traverser ces temps difficiles.
Pour faire court, le monsieur vient dans mon bureau,
en super costume et cravate.
Je lui ai donné ce que je pensais être une brillante explication
de la situation politique et lui ai expliqué à quel point la guerre
serait rude et difficile.
En fait, j'ai sous-estimé les atrocités, je dois l'admettre.
De toute façon, après toute cette grande et longue explication,
la seule question qu'il eut pour moi -- et ce n'est pas une blague --
est, est-ce qu'on paie une redevance quand on diffuse la musique
de Michael Jackson?
C'était vraiment la seule question qu'il avait.
Il est parti, et je me souviens avoir été très en colère contre moi-même
parce que je pensais qu'il devait au moins y avoir une institution dans le monde
qui accordait des prêts aux entreprises médiatiques.
C'est tellement évident, ça saute aux yeux,,
et quelqu'un devait y avoir pensé.
Quelqu'un devait avoir commencé quelque chose comme ça.
Et je pensais, je suis juste idiot et je ne peux pas la trouver.
Vous savez, pour ma défense, il n'y avait pas de Google à l'époque;
vous ne pouviez pas chercher sur Google en 91.
Alors je pensais que c'était en fait mon problème.
Maintenant, à partir de là, avançons rapidement jusqu'en 1995.
J'ai -- J'ai quitté le pays, j'ai rencontré George Soros,
essayant pour la troisième fois de le convaincre qu'il devrait --
sa fondation devrait investir dans quelque chose qui devrait
fonctionner comme une banque médiatique.
Et en gros, ce que je disais était très simple.
Vous savez, oubliez la charité, ça ne marche pas;
oubliez les subventions, 20 000 dollars n'aideront personne.
Ce que vous devriez faire c'est gérer les sociétés médiatiques comme une affaire.
C'est le monde des affaires partout.
Les affaires des médias, ou n'importe quelle autre affaire, a besoin d'être capitalisée.
Et ce dont ces gens ont besoin en fait, c'est d'un accès au capital.
Alors troisième rendez-vous, les arguments sont assez affutés.
A la fin du rendez-vous, il dit,
écoute, ça ne va pas marcher, vous ne reverrez jamais votre argent.
Mais ma fondation investira 500 000 dollars pour que vous testiez l'idée.
Vois et -- vois que ça ne marchera pas.
Il m'a dit, je vais vous donner la corde pour que vous vous pendiez.
(Rires)
Je savais deux choses après ce rendez-vous.
Premièrement, en aucun cas je n'allais me pendre.
Et deuxièmement, que je n'ai aucune idée de comment faire pour que ça marche.
Vous voyez, en tant que concept, c'était un concept brillant .
Mais c'est une chose d'avoir un concept,
et c'est une chose complètement différente de le faire fonctionner.
Donc je n'avais absolument aucune idée de la façon dont cela pouvait marcher.
J'avais la mauvaise idée, je pensais que nous pouvions être une banque.
Voyez les banques, je ne sais pas si il y a des banquiers parmi vous,
Je m'excuse à l'avance, mais c'est le meilleur boulot du monde.
Vous voyez, vous trouvez quelqu'un qui est respectable
et qui a beaucoup d'argent.
Vous leur donnez plus d'argent; ils vous le remboursent après un moment.
Vous collectez les intérêts et ne faites rien d'autre.
Alors j'ai pensé, pourquoi pas le faire?
(Rires)
Donc nous voilà avec notre premier client, génial.
Premier journal indépendant de Slovaquie.
Le gouvernement les isolant
de toutes les imprimeries de Bratislava.
Alors voilà le quotidien,
qui doit être imprimé à 400 kilomètres de la capitale.
C'est un quotidien avec 16h comme heure limite.
Cela signifie qu'ils n'ont pas de sport,
pas de nouvelles de dernière minute, la circulation baisse.
C'est une sorte de façon gentille et raffinée
d'étrangler un quotidien économiquement.
Ils viennent nous voir pour demander un emprunt.
Ils veulent -- la seule façon pour eux de survivre
est d'obtenir un accès à l'impression.
Et nous leur disons, qu'il y a -- c'est d'accord, fixons un rendez-vous,
vous nous apporterez votre plan d'affaire, ce qu'ils ont fait au final.
Nous commençons le rendez-vous.
Je reçois ces deux morceaux de papiers, pas comme ça, format A4,
donc c'est beaucoup plus grand.
Avec beaucoup de chiffres. Beaucoup de chiffres.
Mais quelle que soit la façon dont vous les mettiez, vous savez, les chiffres
cela n'avait aucun sens.
Et c'était le mieux qu'ils pouvaient faire.
Nous étions le mieux qu'ils pouvaient faire.
Alors c'est de cette façon que nous avons compris ce qu'est notre méthode.
Ce n'est pas une banque. Nous devions en fait
aller vers ces entreprises et gagner notre remboursement
en les réparant -- en établissant des systèmes de management,
en fournissant toute la connaissance, comment diriger une affaire
d'un côté -- pendant qu'ils savaient tous comment diriger, comment créer du contenu.
Voyons rapidement les résultats.
En 10 ans, 40 millions de dollars de financement bon marché,
avec un taux d'intérêt entre 5 et 6 pour cent.
Plus tard nous allions nous déchaîner; nous allions faire payer 7 pour cent de temps en temps.
Nous l'avons fait dans 17 pays en développement.
Et voilà le chiffre le plus stupéfiant.
le retour sur investissement -- celui à propos duquel Soros était tellement inquiet -- 97 pour cent.
97 pour cent de tous les remboursements prévus nous sont revenu en temps et en heure.
Qu'est-ce que nous finançons généralement?
Nous finançons tout ce dont une société médiatique pourrait avoir besoin,
des presses typographiques aux émetteurs.
Le plus important c'est que nous le faisons
soit par le biais de prêts, participations, bails --
tout ce qui est approprié pour, vous savez, aider n'importe qui.
Mais le plus important ici est, qui nous finançons?
Nous pensons que dans les 10 dernières années, les sociétés
que nous avons financé sont en fait les meilleurs sociétés médiatiques
dans les pays en développement.
C'est une liste de "Qui est Qui".
Et je pourrais passer des heures à parler d'eux,
parce que ce sont tous des héros en quelque sorte.
Et je peux, mais je -- je vais juste vous en donner une,
et en fonction du temps je pourrais vous donner deux exemples
de personnes avec qui nous travaillons.
Voyez, nous avons commencé à travailler en Europe de l'Est et Europe centrale,
et après nous nous sommes déplacés en Russie.
Notre premier prêt en Russie était à Chelyabinsk.
Je parie que la moitié d'entre vous n'ont jamais entendu parlé de cet endroit.
Dans le sud de la Russie, il y a un type appelé
Boris Nikolayevich Kirshin, qui dirige
un journal indépendant là-bas.
La ville était fermée jusqu'au début des années 90
entre autres, ils produisaient du verre pour des avions Tupolev.
De toute façon, il dirige un journal indépendant là-bas.
Après deux ans à travailler avec nous, il devient
le journal le plus respecté du coin.
Un jour le gouverneur vient le voir,
en fait l'invite à venir dans son bureau.
Il y va pour voir le gouverneur. Le gouverneur dit,
Boris Nikolayevich, je crois comprendre que vous faites du très bon boulot,
et vous êtes le journal le plus respecté de notre district.
Et je veux vous proposer un marché.
Pouvez-vous me donner votre journal pour les neuf prochains mois,
parce que j'ai des élections --
il y a des élections dans neuf mois.
Je ne vais pas y participer mais c'est très important pour moi
de voir qui me succèdera.
Alors donnez-moi le journal pour neuf mois, je vous le rendrai après.
Je n'ai pas d'intérêt à prendre part au marché des médias.
Combien cela coûterait il?
Boris Nikolayevich dit, "Ce n'est pas à vendre."
Le gouverneur dit, "Nous allons vous fermer."
Boris Nikolayevich dit, "Non, vous ne pouvez pas."
Six mois après, le journal était fermé.
Heureusement nous avions eu assez de temps pour aider Boris Nikolayevich
à retirer tous les actifs de l'entreprise pour l'amener dans une nouvelle,
pour prendre toutes les listes d'abonnement, réengager du personnel.
Alors ce que le gouverneur obtient était une coquille vide.
Mais c'est ce qui se produit si vous êtes dans les affaires des médias indépendants,
et si vous êtes une banquier pour les médias indépendants.
Alors cela ressemble à une belle histoire.
Quelque part en chemin nous avons ouvert un centre de gestion des médias.
Nous avons commencé notre laboratoire médiatique, ça semble être une histoire fabuleuse.
Mais on peut voir ça sous un autre angle.
L'autre angle, comme dans cette vidéo.
Si vous mettez la caméra au-dessus, vous recommencez à penser
à ces chiffres.
40 millions de dollars sur 10 ans, répartis dans 17 pays.
Ce n'est pas beaucoup, n'est ce pas?
En fait c'est juste une goutte d'eau dans la mer.
Parce que quand vous pensez à l'importance
des problèmes dont nous discutions la nuit dernière --
cette dernière session que nous avons eu à propos de l'Afrique et de ses
50 milliards de dollars hypothétiques qui leur étaient destinés.
Tous ceux-là, pas tous, la moitié de ces problèmes mentionnés la nuit dernière --
la responsabilité gouvernementale, la corruption, comment lutter contre la corruption,
donner la parole à ceux qui ne sont pas écoutés, aux pauvres --
c'est la raison d'être des médias indépendants.
Et c'est pour cela qu'il fut inventé.
Alors de cette perspective, ce que nous avons fait est vraiment
une goutte d'eau dans la mer de ce besoin que nous pouvons identifier.
Maintenant notre histoire ne reste qu'une histoire.
Je suis sûr que dans cette pièce, il y a, au moins, 15 autres merveilleuses histoires
de sociétés à but non lucratif faisant un travail extraordinaire.
Voilà où est le problème,
et je vous expliquerai du mieux que je peux, quel est le problème.
Et cela a un nom : collecte de fonds.
Imaginez que ce tiers de la salle est rempli
de gens qui représentent différentes fondations.
Imaginez deux tiers juste là à la tête d'excellentes organisations,
effectuant un travail important.
Maintenant imaginez que chaque personne là-bas
est sourde, n'entend pas, and éteint la lumière.
Maintenant on se rend compte à quel point c'est difficile d'assortir les gens
de ce côté de la pièce
avec d'autres de l'autre côté.
Alors nous avons pensé qu'une grande idée était nécessaire
pour réformer, pour repenser entièrement la collecte de fonds.
Vous savez, au lieu d'avoir des personnes se déplaçant dans le noir,
essayant de trouver la bonne personne, qui serait partante,
qui aurait les mêmes buts
A la place de tout ça nous avons pensé que --
qu'il faut inventer quelque chose de nouveau.
Et nous avons eu cette idée d'émettre des obligations,
des obligations de liberté de la presse.
Si il y a des investisseurs prêt à financer
le déficit budgétaire du gouvernement Américain,
pourquoi n'y aurait il pas des investisseurs prêt à financer
le déficit de la liberté de la presse?
Nous avons décidé de faire ça cet automne; nous les distribuerons
probablement à la valeur de 1 000 dollars.
Je ne veux pas leur faire trop de publicité, ce n'est pas le but.
Mais le but, si nous survivons pour les émettre vraiment,
est de trouver assez d'investisseurs pour que cela soit considéré comme un succès,
il n'y a rien qui empêche la prochaine organisation
de commencer à émettre des obligations au printemps prochain.
Et ça peut très bien être des obligations environnementales.
Et alors, deux semaines plus tard, Iqbal Quadir peut distribuer des
obligations pour de l'électricité au Bangladesh.
Et avant que vous n'ayez le temps de dire ouf, n'importe quelle cause sociale
pourra être financée de cette façon.
Maintenant, à 11:30, nous rêvons éveillé pendant encore 55 secondes.
Mais poussons l'idée plus loin.
Vous le faites, vous le lancez aux Etats-Unis, parce que c'est,
vous savez, des concepts qui sont très très chers aux Américains.
Mais en fait, vous pouvez l'amener en Europe aussi.
Vous pouvez l'amener en Asie.
Vous pouvez, une fois que vous avez tous ces différents points,
vous pouvez le rendre plus facile pour les investisseurs.
Mettre toutes ces obligations à un seul endroit
et ils s'asseyent et cliquent.
Une fois que vous avez plus de 10 investisseurs
vous devez développer une sorte de matrice.
Qu'est ce que les investisseurs obtiennent?
D'un côté, du financier, de l'autre côté, du social.
Alors cela amène l'idée d'une sorte d'agence de notation,
un peu comme Morningstar.
Ça dit, vous savez, l'impact social ici est spectaculaire, cinq étoiles.
La finance vous rapporte un pour cent, seulement une étoile.
Maintenant atteignons la dernière étape.
Une fois que vous avez tout cela mit ensemble,
il n'y a pas de raison de ne pas avoir
un marché pour tout ça
où vous pouvez disposer de toutes ces obligations d'une façon plutôt rapide.
Et de la façon dont vous organisez le financement
pour qu'il n'y ait pas de pièce obscure, pas de personnes aveugles
essayant désespérément de se trouver les uns les autres.
Merci.